[Music]
the minute a lion becomes aware of you
and you become aware of it you are in a
language dialogue and it is a language
of energy and presence
now there's usually one of two things
that will happen
either the lion will get up and this is
99 of the encounters the lions
natural instinct is to get away from you
remember people hunted lions for
hundreds of years on the plains and
actually one of the primary ways that
hunter-gatherers got food
and a lot of people don't know this is
they tracked lions and then they would
rob them of their kills and so lions
have a long history of being you know
chased by humans so normally it'll go
away from you however that doesn't
always happen
particularly if if a lioness has cubs or
if they or if they have meat they can be
aggressive
now normally what will happen is the
first thing that you will notice
is the animal's body will tighten
they'll drop their head and the tail
starts to flick intensely and they start
to warning growl at you
it sounds like the growl is so intense
it sounds like someone started a dirt
bike in the bush up ahead of you
and then
if it's a lioness and she's got cubs
she'll stand up and still with her head
low and her ears back and the tail
lashing she slowly starts to walk
towards you
and she fixes you with a gaze
of utter intensity and the minute she
has you in that gaze
your only option
is you have to stand your ground and you
have to communicate an intense presence
back to her
so
when that happens to me if i feel myself
starting to come into an encounter where
we're going to have a
more aggressive energetic conversation
with each other and may i just interject
for one second to say when you don't
have clients
true or false you guys will often go out
with just walking sticks yeah no no
rifles without clients okay please
continue what we most believe in is
being in this dialogue
and so if that happens the first thing
that you do is you breathe out a long
out breath
because everything in your system is
starting to jack up because the feeling
of it is like i'm i mean you can feel
your whole system flush with
with uh adrenaline so you breathe out
you anchor yourself
and
then you understand that that line is
trying to communicate with you she walks
towards you intensely intensely and then
she'll growl
and with that she charges and then she
runs at you at full speed and it is in
it's so fast
uh snarling you know full guns revealed
teeth revealed and she comes in
and then you stand your ground and you
look her directly in the eyes
and
mostly what'll happen is she'll stop
some distance from you as she stops you
hold her in your energy and you almost
aggressive back to her and you're
showing that like i'm dangerous too
and then the minute you see her energy
drop a little bit because all that she's
doing is she's trying to anchor you so
that the cubs can run away the minute
you see her energy drop a little bit you
just start dropping away and you give
her still facing her you step back you
give her space and very quickly you
start communicating to her that we we
know we've come too close but we're
going to give you space now but you can
only do that once she has stopped coming
at you and you'll if you watch her very
intensely and renis is really the master
of this as you watch her closely a
slight drop in energy and he'll move
backwards a little bit
and then you you know get out of the
situation and you just find yourself
giggling stupidly
and doing all the weird things that
happen after high tense situations
so you said most of the time they
stopped some distance from you so
what
what's the alternate scenario
if you're in the alternate scenario
you've got something very very wrong
yeah
and the reason that you get into the
alternate scenario
is that you get it wrong in the moment
you see as that charge starts happening
you're in the dialogue and your and your
presence is absolutely critical in your
ability to project an energetic presence
and meet her and then for to quickly
help her understand that you're not
afraid of her you're dangerous but
you're also going to give way
and and when people get killed it's
because they get that wrong they fall
over their nerve breaks and they want to
run or they get scared and they start
running immediately that's when
dangerous things happen
you